And welcome back.
We are now on number
seven on page 409.
Dwayne has a newspaper route
for which he collects k
dollars per day.
From this amount, he pays out--
so this is how much he
makes-- k/3 dollars per day
for the cost of the paper.
So this is cost of papers.
And he saves the rest
of the money.
In terms of k, how many
days will it take
Dwayne to save $1,000?
That's his goal.
Well, how much does
he make per day?
Well, he makes k, and he has
to give out k/3 per day.
So each day, per day, he
makes k minus k/3.
We could write this
as 3k minus k/3.
k is the same thing is 3k/3.
So this is equal to 2k/3.
That's how much he
makes per day.
So how much does he
make in d days?
If d is the number of days,
how much does he make?
Well, he makes 2k/3 times d.
That's how much he makes,
right? d days.
Well, he wants to make $1,000,
so how many days
is it going to take?
Hopefully, you realize this is
a level one linear equation,
so you multiply both sides
times a reciprocal.
So 3/2k times this,
times 3/2k.
This cancels this.
This cancels.
That cancels.
You're just left with a d
on the left-hand side.
And on the right-hand side, we
can do little canceling, too.
This 2 will cancel and
make this into 500.
You have 500 times 3/k.
So that equals-- I don't know
why I started tilting-- that
equals 1500/k days.
And that is the choice
number D.
All right.
I get excited.
Number eight has
a number line.
I get excited whenever there's
a number line problem.
I don't know why.
It's a psychological
disorder, perhaps.
But a good one.
Some abnormalities are positive
abnormalities.
Let's see.
So let me draw this
number line.
All right.
I drew that number line.
That's a number line.
Most of the time is probably
just going to take drawing it.
Let me do this in a
different color.
So I have point A.
Let me do it in a more
vivid color.
Point A is here, and then it's
right next to negative 2.
It's a little bit less
than negative 2,
which is right there.
Then I have negative
1 right here.
Then I got a bunch of points.
I have B.
I have P.
I have C.
Then I have 0.
Then I have 1.
And then I have a couple
points more.
D.
And then I have Q.
Then I have the number
2, and I have E.
All right.
So let's read the problem.
Which of the letter points, on
the number line above, could
represent the result when the
coordinate of point P is
multiplied by the coordinate
of point Q.
All right.
So this is pretty much just an
approximation problem, right?
So we're trying to figure out
P times Q, essentially.
So point P, well, let's eyeball
it, it's a little bit
to the left of 0, to the
right of negative 1.
It looks like maybe, I
don't know, I'm just
guessing, minus 0.5?
minus 1/2, right?
Minus 1/2.
And what's Q?
Well, Q looks a little bit
closer to 2 than it is to 1,
so I would say maybe,
1 and 3/4?
I'm just guessing.
You could just approximate
it as you want.
So 1 and 3/4.
Or if you wanted to write that
as an improper fraction, which
I prefer to deal with, 7/4.
I'm just eyeballing it.
Nothing fancy here.
So if P is minus 1/2, and this
number is 7/4, what happens
when you multiply the two?
So minus 1/2 times 7/4 is equal
to minus 7/8, right?
So minus 7/8, that's
almost minus 8/8.
Minus 8/8 would be here.
Minus 8/8 would be at negative
1, and so this is a little
less negative, so it's a
slightly larger number.
So minus 7/8 is going to be
someplace around this area.
Well, it's interesting that
I've bumped into a number
there while I was looking
in that area.
I bumped into point B.
And maybe my approximation
is wrong.
Maybe it could be point P.
But when I look at the
choices, P isn't a
choice, and only B is.
So B is what I would bubble in,
as what happens when you
multiply P times Q.
And that was kind of fun,
because it's just pure
approximation.
And you kind of get something
that approaches the answer.
Well, it is the answer I guess.
Hopefully.
All right.
I'm having too much fun,
absolutely too much fun.
OK.
Number nine.
If 5y plus 2x is equal to 23,
and x is equal to y plus 1,
what is the value of y?
What does y equal?
Well, this we could
do straight up
substitution to solve.
We have x is equal
to y plus 1.
Substitute.
Substitute for x.
So then we're left with
5y plus 2 times x.
For x, we substitute
this term.
2 times y plus 1
is equal to 23.
We just do algebra, or
even arithmetic.
5y plus-- distribute the 2--
2y plus 2 is equal to 23.
5y plus 2y is 7y, plus
2 is equal to 23.
Subtract 2 from both sides.
7y is equal to 21.
y is equal to 3.
This was just a question to see
if you even took Algebra
I, not to make you feel bad
if you don't remember.
People forget things.
But anyway, let's move on.
Number 10.
A company produced 300
appliances in the first week
of the month.
So this is number
10 we're doing.
Let me switch colors because
that mauve is too dark.
So week one.
Appliances.
Produced 500 in week one.
Because it received additional
machinery, its production
increased 50% from the first
week to the second week.
How many appliances did
the company produce
in the second week?
Well, I didn't even have to
make a table here, right?
So it improved 50%.
So plus 50%.
So it's important.
It improved 50% percent.
Week 2 isn't 50% percent of 500,
it's 50% more than 500.
So it's 500 plus 50% of 500.
What's 50% percent of 500?
Well, that's 250, right?
So it's 250 plus 500 is 750.
I was looking forward to
something more challenging.
Anyway, number 11.
Let's see if I have time to do
number 11 in this video.
You know what?
I only have one minute left.
I will do this in
the next video.
See you soon.